all right welcome back to Hannity we
have more reaction to the spot mustard
news about James Comey and am a second
exoneration of Hillary before the
investigation was even complete let me
let me just stay on what he is
exonerating here because we know the
mishandling of classified top secret
special access program information we
know that was on that server in the
mom-and-pop shop bathroom closet by the
way we know that she destroyed such
information we know that she lied when
she said she didn't have this
information on there that she didn't
send her receive that's been debunked
then you've got the whole thing about
deleting 33,000 subpoenaed emails then
you got the acid wash and the use of
bleach bit most Americans had never
heard of it before then you've got an
aide busting up devices blackberries and
the like with hammers and the only thing
they turn over to the FBI in terms of a
device is one without a SIM card
rendering it useless for the FBI
now that sounds to me it is obvious that
laws were broken here and that we now
know five foreign agencies tapped into
that that particular server that
compromised national security
so does that mean now that the fix is in
with Comey instructed we got to go back
and do it all over again well I think a
couple things here first of all there's
a report out today that she apparently
had a deal I haven't seen the exact
language yet but she apparently to deal
with the Obama administration that
allowed she and her top aides to take
away whatever they wanted to which
apparently included an entire section on
her outreach to the Muslim community in
the Middle East I mean that this first
of all the the Obama administration
didn't have the authority to violate law
by having this kind of a deal but second
this is a whole new zone that just
showed up during the day today as a
report of a special arrangement that she
had made to be able to take all this
stuff away even though that was with the
Obama administration terms of security
with the Obama station so so let me let
me draw this into two parts for a second
Sean
part one is Hillary and the entire gang
from the from the foundation through her
aides etc that's got to be reopened part
two is the level of corruption and
dishonesty in the FBI and the gin digit
and the Justice Department that's an
entire new case both of these cases I
think the Congress has to insist and
frankly attorney General Sessions has to
insist that both of these are going to
be pursued not not as a matter of
vengeance not to go after people but
because the rule of law the very base of
the American system requires that we
take seriously when powerful people are
corrupted and you have both a Clinton
corruption and a Comey FBI corruption
those are two separate cases they both
have to be brought to light and people
have to be prosecuted I always thought
that it was a mistake that Jeff Sessions
recused himself here and you got rot
Rosenstein the way way wait wait wait
wait okay he has not recused himself on
any of this he recused himself narrowly
on the Russian investigation about
whether or not the Trump campaign was
involved but as Attorney General he's
not recused on whether or not the FBI
was were corrupted and he's not recused
on whether or not the Clinton team was
correct I was specifically so an
absolute obligation yeah I agree with
you I also didn't recuse himself on
uranium one or on the dossier because
again that came up later to you know
tell me the atomic though he say there's
no straight let me send it straight for
a second because I've known Jeff
Sessions a long time and I'll just say
flatly it's time for the Attorney
General to step up to the plate and do
his job he has no excuse as somebody who
I know believes in the law he has no
excuse for hiding he has to has to set
up a Clinton investigation he has to set
up an FBI Justice Department
investigation
this is his obligation under the law to
enforce it and to protect the American
people and and Jeff Sessions has nowhere
to hide on this he can't recuse himself
he can't say he's not involved these two
they're so profound that he has to take
them head-on or he's frankly not doing
his job I don't think I could say it any
better it's serious we will stay on it
interesting isn't it sad probably the
biggest news story in our lifetime
politically and the news media in this
country has basically ignored it and has
they've been co-opted by a phony
narrative and that they are spreading
lies and and fake news for a year and
being caught regularly at it last word
well look this this is the beginning of
the end of their world
if the Clintons go down as hard as I
think they're going to and if the
corruption of the FBI goes down as hard
as it's going to then the the elite
media will have been more severely
damaged than any time in the last 50
years
chilling mr. speaker we'll stay on it I
promise this is a huge story